[موسيقى]
ادم الشرقاوي اهلا بك معنا ادم دور سامح
في مسلسل الف حمد لله على السلامه مع
الفنانه الكبيره يسرا جات لك الفرصه دي
ازاي
قالوا في دور مع استاذ يسرا في رمضان
دور سامح هو
ابن استاذ يسرا جاي من بره
والورق حلو فاقرا وشوف ايه رايك نريت
عجبني اول الموضوع شفت ان فكره المسلسل
كانت حلوه قوي وانا هقدر اعمل حاجه شغلك
مع الفنانه يسرا كلمني كده عن الاجواء
بتاعته واتعلمت منها ايه اتعلمت حاجات
كتير قوي
اول حاجه يعني بني ادم ازاي يعني تتعامل
مع المشاكل
وفي التصوير ازاي تتعامل باكتر طريقه
وازاي تبقى هادي
في لعبه نيوتن مصري دور مصري عايش في
امريكا وانت فعلا انت كادام انت مصري كنت
عايش في امريكا هل مش خايف ان ده يحصرك في
المنطقه دي سامح وبيجزي مش شبه بعض خالص
غير في طريقه الكلام
وانا برضه في خمس جولات عملت دور حد مصري
مصري انا مش خايف ان انا هتحط في الحته دي
وفي نفس الوقت مش عايز اضيع الحته دي عشان
دي حته مني يعني ده ده انا انت دخلت مجال
التمثيل في مصر ازاي انا عملت في امريكا
لعبه نيوتن
الكاستنج
انا عملته فهي قالت فيه دور لواحد مصري
عايش بره تعال اعمل
فعملت اول كان وحش قوي قوي انا حتى قلت
لامي مستحيل اخد الدور ده مستحيل بس استاذ
تامر شاف
هو قال تعالى ونجرب حاجه وعملت ايه بقى
بعد لعبه نيوتن
نزلت انا قلت لازم اعيش هنا فتره عشان
اتعلم اول حاجه العربي
واغير تفكيري ابتدي افكر
في شبه المصريين عشان برضو في في اختلاف
في يعني الاماكن كوتشر مش شبه المصري فكنت
بس عايز اتعلم يعني افهم افهم مصر اشتغلت
ايه السينما خمس جولات اللي ممكن اتكلم
اكتر خمس جولات انا برضو فارس بلعب شخصيه
اسمها اسمه فارس
فده بيتكلم عن رحله واحد بيحاول يوصل
لبطوله ام ام ايه معين ابقى هتكمل في الفن
في مصر ولا بره
سؤال صعب سؤال صعب بس عاجبني قوي عاجبني
قوي بصراحه عشان
انا مش عارف ده احسن رد على السؤال انا
انا انا بجد مش عارف انا هبقى بين هنا
وهناك طبعا طبعا
على حسب الشغل يعني مثلا السنه اللي فاتت
انا عملت فيلم واحد في امريكا
ده نزل على نتفليكس
بس نادي لسه ما صورتش حاجه جالي فرص تصور
حاجه هناك بس الوقت ما كانش مناسب كنت
بصور لسه هنا في رمضان وانا شفت ان لا
الشغل هنا مع استاذه يسرا هيساعدني اكتر
من البروجكت اللي انا هعمله هناك فانا
بحاول اوزن الحاجات كده لمتابعه المزيد من
الاخبار والبرامج والقصص الانسانيه
والوثائقيات والتقارير الاخباريه لا تنسوا
الاشتراك في قناتنا على اليوتيوب الضغط
على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل جرس التنبيهات